écoutez je pense que vous prenez des
petits bouts de choses vous les mettez
ensemble pour essayer de faire une
histoire on pourrait par exemple dire
que je suis déconstructionniste ok vous
avez vu la polémique sur yale yale c'est
le petit robert le petit robert s'est
dit is
editis et vincent bolloré dont vincent
bolloré est déconstructionniste voilà
vous avez des dizaines de milliers
d'heures sur nos programmes voilà et
quant à zemmour pardonnez moi mais il
est il publier des livres à des
centaines de milliers d'exemplaires bien
avant qu'il ne revienne sur ses news je
vous rappelle qu'il est sur le figaro je
vous rappelle qu'il est sur l'a6 et
comme par hasard c'est quand il est sur
ces news les avons problème mais je
redis il ya tellement de courant de
pensée dans nos livres dans nos
émissions
voilà personne ne pensait personne ne
savait qu'ils allaient de président de
la république franchement c'est pas
raisonnable
[Musique]